hey guys i'm ryan right i am jerry guys
guys I was just on screen junkies movie
fights so that should be up by February
27 don't know if this video is up after
February 27th or before because I'm not
from the future this is the past you are
watching right now watch it isn't like
an hour and a half it took anyway so I'm
bringing that up because people have
been requesting specifically Jerry and I
check out the honest trailer for the
Oscars oh wow they did a trailer for the
Oscar and I've seen most of the Oscar
nominated Best Picture films okay I've
seen most of them I haven't seen all of
them there's some I haven't seen but
I've seen most of them do you feel like
you understand what a franchise I'm not
sure could you clear
in a world where a bunch of rich people
dress up in fancy clothes to give each
other trophies these eight films will
compete for Hollywood's highest honor
being the answer to the question what
did win the Oscar last year the honest
nominees for Best Picture are from Adam
McKay the guy who brought you Talladega
Nights stepbrothers and anchorman 2
comes a sobering look at the financial
crisis of 2008 wait what so Wall Street
crashes the economy for profit it got
away with it I would be so outraged
right now if I understood what the hell
was going on huh is subprime
sorry Margot Robbie I appreciate that
you're in a bath of it all but I still
get it no money mo problems gear up for
the most badass nominee for Best Picture
since ever
as George Miller's brutal world blurs
the line between apocalyptic madness and
Australian people being Australian he's
a crazy Smeg who eats schlanger
hey it's nominated for Best Picture not
Best Screenplay all right furiosa Road
featuring that backs deep in the woods
of North Dakota revenge is a dish best
served cold like so cold you have to
sleep inside a horse but we really want
to do an actual honest trailer for this
movie and we don't have the footage yet
so we're sitting our best jokes were
later
long story short Leo grunts his way to
an Oscar frozen journey back to a time
when you on my paper and delivered to
your home before a movie that really
nails the look and feel of Boston that
Bostonians probably wish was said
literally anywhere else 90 priests is
that possible but don't worry they're
everywhere in this well-acted super
depressing episode of Dateline NBC that
made audiences everywhere say great I
probably live next to a pedophile priest
- Newsies might want to avoid these
houses from Steven Spielberg and Tom
Hanks comes a competently made by the
numbers drama about the
Cold War that your dad definitely saw
and you'll probably catch on a plane
some time but when you're Steven
Spielberg and Tom Hanks even your
average movies get nominated for Best
Picture by default hey they both done
better than this but come on they've
earned it
not nearly enough spies your favorite
sci-fi movies and also Prometheus comes
to that's basically castaway in space
which was technically already gravity
which makes this gravity on Mars so hold
on to your sides for what the Golden
Globes declared the best comedy of the
year I die I need you to check him
parents I know that sucks talking to it
a couple about their dead son then you
get it it's funny because he thinks he's
never gonna see his family again at bars
in the city of Brooklyn I sue and in
comes the story of an immigrant lady who
falls in love with her
I'll be honest I haven't seen Brooklyn
and either of you here zero for one of
the best movies of the year which
unfortunately almost shares a title with
the worst movie of all
please nature's a major engine and
direction but it's so depressing we're
just gonna run all the times they say
room in the movie railroad room room bro
bro bro bro
well Wow double starring the larious
Matt Damon Leonardo Det Oscar doe Dom
Hannam Gleeson belts a lady driver okay
there tummy to wrap it up okay uh our
fader even-tempered max oh man so many
names okay okay um saber-toothed large
yo Rick okay
Turner and Russkies a pedophile priests
aa rapist
um the evil banks oh sorry see Rory we
thrown in um I don't have time for that
one and I and no black people the Oscars
the big show was great but let's be
honest it wasn't the best movie about
five guys trying to stick it to the man
this year I got some nasarah be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers hey
screen junkies want to watch the Oscars
with us then I'm into our live Oscar
watch party right here on YouTube
featuring your favorite screen junkies
personalities the stream starts this
Sunday at 5 p.m. Pacific time as a
remark honest take on this year's
ceremony yeah and since everyone in
Hollywood is giving stuff away we're
giving you a chance to win a free
one-year subscription to screen junkies
plus check the link in the description
below where you a chance to take home
screen junkies gold superhero landing
she's gonna do a superhero landing I
love apples and bananas weenus cable guy
I pooped my pants and told no one a
journey of a thousand miles begins with
a cinch step haha ah damn that poor guy
okay Wow brilliant stuff man I really
love the creativity behind what they
you you know when you like go to their
actual offices it's like man this is
this is not what I currently do there's
there's a lot of people working hearing
this isn't a building that has
architecture yeah they're like other and
sweet whatever number and then you like
it you walk in they have like multiple
suites that lasts and horrible like
solarium yeah skyscraper is really close
it was really [ __ ] cool is is really
inspiring to a nice ignores just someone
who's so [ __ ] bit he's like creator
of honest trailers and he is so busy all
the time it's cool because he like this
guy seems like a really chill dude
especially on camera we you see this
guy's like you know Hazen's he's all
he's a hustler yeah he's in the second
sure shits in life it's a scene like the
creativity behind what they do here it's
like they efficiently give us new
observations back with things we want to
them to point out that we've had heard
before like the Martian with the comedy
you know like a lot of people have been
commenting on that it's like if they
took the most memorable moments out of a
hypothetical Martian trailer or a
trailer for any of these movies and just
made like a bite-size version yeah
exactly
honestly this is a great way if you
haven't seen all the Oscar movies I now
know a little bit about I mean the only
ones I haven't seen are Brooklyn Reuben
you don't know anything I don't know
anything about Brooklyn yeah but what's
her name Sasha Sasha Ronan yeah she's
like a hot alien you know I mean she's
like an attractive ethereal alien uh
like an extraterrestrial human or an
essence yeah she's really good the grand
Budapest hotel and the host as you
respect that they pointed out Straight
Outta Compton was probably a more you
know a much better movie and that movie
moved people everyone who watched it was
like have you seen Straight Outta
Compton
it's really good I don't know it's weird
cuz they put in they expanded the Best
Picture category
don't they have ten slots like eight now
yeah it's eight now but it's like you
had ten like two years ago oh yeah
they're like why not nominate I don't
know is anyone really gonna care about
the Oscars after it's done yeah no no
we're I mean it's hard to say I mean
like yeah people do care like if you
hear that something is Oscar
award-winning people are like oh it
might be pretty good cuz I used to I
grew up watching every Oscar event then
it got to a point where I was like these
are starting to seem a little lazy and
then sometimes they seem good again but
there's never the magic anymore that I
feel when I watch the Oscars well yeah
cuz there's a lot of politicking and
there's a lot of like you know movies
don't get seen because of the scope and
scale yeah I like it's a weird award
show in a lot of times Ward's show
awards shows kind of look just serve the
yes what was that that was you going
look is here I going up yeah now I get
some time uh but yeah like you know the
orchards kind of give out like you know
the popular opinion I'm gonna die my
tummy is sorry [ __ ] with you
you say that like every video it cannot
be rare form at this point I've never
seen you that never see me do that um
sorry please finish your point oh I
don't know if I remember what it was
gonna be oh my god I mean the thing of
it the way the Oscars works those like
you never really remember what won an
Academy Award but if you hear something
won an Academy Award you'll be more
likely to check it out yeah it's like so
it doesn't really mean much it's just
the name Academy Award or Oscar means
something yeah totally I just feel like
celebrities used to be way more admire
than they are now in a Hollywood you
know there used to be something that
seems so I don't know like the glamour
behind it it's now it seems like
everyone is you get to a certain age
here like man celebrities or that's just
not a good area to be involved yourself
with and I feel like it makes sense
though cuz like in the older days you
know
you had these big Hollywood stars we had
moving pitches yeah it's like Studios
had contracts with stars and so they
would put them in all these movies and
you know you didn't have you could say
they would mount them in movies not not
smut pictures three times no smut
pictures smut pictures I'm gonna shut it
out they had contracted stars so you'd
see the same names a lot you would see
different pairings you would only ever
hear about the scandals like maybe in
the paper every once in a while but it's
like they could still keep the sort of
otherworldly status you get when you're
an artist and like people you've never
met know who you are like true there's a
mystique and nowadays like the mystique
is cynical because we know that they
have problems now and there are tabloids
and now there's social media now like
everything's busily yeah so when it felt
like a story still stars were bigger I
feel like we don't even really get stars
anymore celebrity you know we used to
have them lights DiCaprio right now I
mean he's a celebrity that's like the
only one I don't know how to put it like
you know there was Tom Cruise and then
there was Brad Pitt and George Clooney
came in at some point and then we
started getting a lot more character
actors that were becoming sexiest man
alive yeah you know start ruining things
maybe that's Jack Michaels well he's
also a highly respected actor as I read
an article once that was something sexy
about at least younger chick a little
bit shining right so there was something
and just writing imagine that here's
Johnny face eating you up here's Johnny
thank you for doing it to life thank you
for reminding me this is what that might
be like you kids enter the guy and we
have fun horror movie moment oh this is
great for filming right yeah yeah so old
Hollywood star I read an article where
is about like how there's celebrities
and then there's movie you know
character actor stars Holy Mother of God
I am never gonna get this point across
with it so [ __ ] it we'll do it live just
just keep going all right Ryan Gosling
to me is the closest between like care
actor slash celebrity DiCaprio - you
know character actor slash celebrity I
don't feel like we have just like a guy
who were like we want to watch them play
themselves Tom Cruise always showed up
kind of doing Tom Cruise ya know I mean
you could argue that the trends are just
cyclical because like the celebrities we
like and we make big you know are kind
of like the heroes it's like you know we
like the people who sort of have either
a problem or are super awesome and so
like those reflect our characters now or
is like in the old days you know there
were more swashbucklers and more sort of
morally straight you know dashing guys
you know and you could associate that
with the celebrities yeah and maybe that
maybe that had a different impact
yeah celebrities had a different image
of like you know they were always in the
suits and stuff like the gland now it's
like we always see photos of celebrities
who are like dress down trying to hide
from the camera the thing that's sort of
I guess what made those movie stars so
like to have that status basically is
like idolized yes it's almost like and I
wasn't there so I don't know for sure
but like hearing about celebrity life
back then and like Hollywood parties
like from anywhere else in the country
it would almost be like a character in
your newspaper each day you're like oh
and then you can look at the decadence
and go home or you can look at their
screw-ups and go huh you know and it
becomes a look at the can okay try and
make sure he includes you guys I'm sorry
good now finish her point uh basically I
think I did don't make things up you are
the wish your point you aren't listening
anyway so you you don't know I could
have finished my point very true very
very from listing guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects the co-creator and co-host
of this channel Jerri Blank is has a
playlist on here called reasons to
charity check it out
dank a Stubbs podcast hosted by Jerry on
the
channel and follow us on Instagram
Twitter vine and our Facebook because
we're actually using three out of four
than consistently yeah
the vines I randomly get into them that
I post like here's like eight vines yeah
you'll go on a vine me yeah leave it for
me yeah exactly exactly anyway um Jerry
is giving me the BJ look so this cameras
gonna go off no just like a nice hug
I'll spoon you or something we can fake
it no all right now